first one there you're asked to expand
this set of brackets hopefully you
recognize that this is not just any
random selection of binomials right they
are I've difference of squares or there
will be difference of squares once you
expand because it's even before
something take away something something
you can take away or add something write
a minus B a plus B that will give you
the straight expansion there's nothing
wrong with just pairing up all the terms
you get something up but obviously this
is quite significantly quicker right it
is 16 in squares the square it is yeah
so one of the tricky thing is if you go
straight there it's a common error to
just write whether we find 4m squared
because one of the students know if
they've written down for its web yeah
they've done they've squared the amber
that I don't know before coming along
for the ride so this is perfect
but the trans that you sort of produce a
budget if you're not careful is
forgetting square the whole thing if it
is so look at this one paper sign pay
pay going six down they add two three I
do multiply to negative two to four okay
the last one you can see Jeb has broken
apart the excuse me the minus 13 in
she's broken apart into our finance for
in and a minor 9 in why did she choose
four and nine being negative or negative
odd I should say because they multiply
together the keys
so do you think because she selected two
correctly when she did preparing it all
matched up and she got the same thing
which she then took out now just before
you start writing the next thing I want
to point out now as you know put you put
you put down I won't rub off what I'm
about to show you on the board just so
that you can see this is not the only
way to do it I didn't want to show you
two methods at the beginning because
then you would get confused with
different choices but not everyone likes
doing it this way is another way and I
want to show you actually there's at
least three more ways but I'm just going
to show you one
at this point here when you've written
down the first line which is the
question and then you think of your
parent numbers splitting them apart like
this is one of the things you could do
but then something else you can do
I'll write it down but I just want you
to watch and then write down when I'm
done using negative form and maybe
advantage since I don't want to write
instead mr. Beckett's right okay
just pause for Ruth see what I've done
okay
I've treated this a little bit like the
Christmas concert which is archived
compare numbers what if it was for Megan
no that's because I just did whatever
your parent numbers was and you place
them here here right but this is not
Manik so I've adjusted it a little bit
I've noticed that what you get is 6n
squared at the end okay so I put a stick
in here sitting here I put it twice
you'll see why in a second but if I did
actually expand this just that numerator
why would you how many N squared which
we end up with Tammy N squared or you
have one term to the N squared in it but
that does have a coefficient of 6 times
6 36 which I actually don't want that's
not what I wanted so I divide by 6 to
try and cook them say for that what what
happens now okay I'm not quite 1 I'm
going to write 6 as 2 times 3 the reason
why I've chosen to try to add 2 times 2
is separated out is because do you
notice out of these two binomials one of
them has a compactor - one of them has
we call factor a train do you see it
this guy here I can divide both of those
by to take out the contract or you get
letter you'd find it by watching
you see that right 5130 and then when I
divide both of these by three I've got
left with just like genitive okay in
mathematics you have lots of different
approaches which do you like better
there's things to like and dislike about
this I'd probably say that it has a bit
of an edge in terms of speed but it's
also a bit random it's like what why
don't why do you listen then undo it
that's a bit strange I could explain it
to you but it's a bit of a long and
winding curve this one probably takes a
bit longer but all of these skills are
important skills you need to have anyway
which is why I talked to you first okay
but either those it's fine